[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys it's good to be here my
name is hans i used to day waiting was
really into yoga and choke sex I was
like do you do everything or not I'm
here people tell me I'm a premature
ejaculator premature to who I can't let
the perfect time when I'm done takes
maturity the man
my name is months came I live in a band
so that I can pursue comedy full-time
say if you don't think I'm funny I'm
sorry I'm trying really hard I know
someone's in the back like yeah that's
funny but not living you're being funny
could've written that you're an
apartment buddy I started dating a man
because ladies love shelter like this
whole thing with them so you're gonna
make as well easy ends up happening is
we go for a drive so I can work up the
courage to tell her we're right 45
minutes ago
surprised a little bit we're gonna be at
I woke up today and I was like I wonder
what the temperature outside is like and
I was like probably exactly the same as
the temperature inside of this man I can
just use the app on my body I think it's
funny that tanner is a white person
saying ten dozen will eat your weight
[ __ ] it should be like hey this
is like Mexican Frank tanner that's what
my dentist joke I am an Asian or those
countries I'm from a Province in China
called South Korea my Asian friends in
quantum either like mangy General Tso's
chicken is not just a shitty
Americanized version of something
authentically Asian I was like yeah I
saw my favorite movies rush hour 3
it's hard being an Asian man you know
Asian women are so much more successful
than us and then like they're better
than us but back home we're doing you
guys away don't really impress me
honestly you look exactly like agent man
I can throw on a wig it be a seven but I
think you're better than because you get
[ __ ] white dudes everyone can [ __ ] white
dudes I mean a lot of people make fun of
Asians also because we tell us which I'm
saying to be very shocking because in
America of dollars if you like family
members but in Asia which your family
members like family members the rule of
tradition we had back home where instead
of buying an animal we love our grandma
she never better need unless you're a
baby girl a lot of mom being Asian you
know a lot of people are racist Asia's
oh you hate respectful people who keep
to themselves okay
we're not fighting in a portable car I
understand the sayings in English they
say in prison don't drop the soap
that's not even helpful it should be
comfor got the soap
they can drop this up as you want yeah
depending over whether they really can't
you you're gonna be done off the self
you're [ __ ] it raise your just kind
of really clean hands while it happens
it was working to get that kid but he
never drops in so I am single I am I am
a heterosexual I hear her [ __ ] here
sorry fellas I never looked at a
beautiful woman I've been I love the
revision number that's bigger and
hairier net was kindness a little bit
that my bubble but brother like dude was
so lucky we're not gay
can you imagine most of the gender we
were attracted to wasn't attracted to it
back and I was like whoa imagine it was
quite a lot I am a bit of a sapiosexual
that means I'm looking for a girlfriend
who is not only beautiful but also
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding meaning attractive
okay all right add tonight
I can figure this out let's solve for X
I think women are very beautiful and I
get in trouble a lot because I stare at
them but it's not my fault
because the video a woman is like a
beautiful scenic sunset I can't yell at
you like a waterfall that call the cops
bound side with pepper spray so they
can't take a picture even though you
kind of want to you know there I love
the ladies
my friend was like do you learn how to
talk to women maybe or maybe women
should learn how to listen to ants why
don't you want to hear about the Federal
Reserve
it's no intricate as the little lady was
like dude you know that my vagina is
technically a 3d printer because it can
make a baby I was like actually your
womb is the 3d printer your vagina is
the tray
and other friends one thing with lots of
mirrors takes nine months to print and
the whole times printing is complaining
this is saying did not say trays that
night I'm blending women get burnt my
godness men gave birth we'd [ __ ] it up
would be like bro I've been eating so
much protein and creatine during my
pregnancy this baby was like 27 pounds
already bro check out a 6-pack of the
ultrasound it's above those keen to the
first trimester healthy breath I
understand homophobia people will be
like it's an Adam and Eve not Adam and
Steve but I don't need we're not even a
good couple typically because first of
all they disobeyed God and native fruit
they want spicy which is tag a there is
Cain and Abel and Cain murdered Abel
what I take Atlantic advice from people
raised a murderer there were like three
other people on earth as [ __ ] killed
a quarter of the world's population get
your [ __ ] together with stardom
the genetic diversity
I am a theist now because I'm not in
kindergarten and they have an internet
connection I think it'd be stressful to
have an ideology that you could destroy
by acts is walking down the street oh
look boss oh [ __ ] I guess the comment
blowing through this whole time what a
Tuesday I I love you know if humanity
had the capitalism is great if you want
to do it but don't make everyone play
your stupid game
I like fortnight I don't make your
grandma play and take warehouses she's
losing surprise like I love a good job
so when you're baking cookies
I love how Americans will say communism
never works as if we didn't spend
billions of dollars and kill millions of
people to make sure it wouldn't work
remember the war in Vietnam the Bay of
Pigs Nicaragua Panama we're pretty
anxious about it that working we're
giving 110%
communism never works because whatever
people control the means of production
the democratically elected leaders
mysteriously died and a small rebel
group always finds automatic weapons
themselves where you staple is you some
point you to stabilizers I'm not a
communist but I do support any policies
that Republicans consider communism
which is whenever two or more people
gathered
nice everybody they got in